samedi jour de marché hebdomadaire à
versailles et sur la place saint louis
des stands de restaurateurs l'opération
nationale place au resto lancée il ya
plus d'un mois est organisé par
metrofrance et des fédérations
professionnelles en partenariat avec les
mairies
le dispositif permet aux restaurateurs
de pouvoir venir les jours de marché
avec des emplacements gratuits pour
vendre des plats chauds à remporter nous
on fait des opérations qui permettent
qui leur permet de de survivre et puis
le client collègues c'est pas non plus
la panacée mais au moins ça permet
d'avoir une visibilité ça permet aussi
de respirer un peu pour les
restaurateurs cette opération est une
aubaine mais aussi une nouvelle
organisation en mode click and collect
je trouve que c'est bien ce que la ville
de versailles a fait c'est de çà permet
aux restaurateurs de pouvoir se montrer
s'afficher en fait c'est un deuxième
pôle de distribution d'envoi c'est
vachement bien
ça c'est grâce à mes trois aussi ils ont
les moyens parce que chez nous et nous
prête des machines métro étant le
premier fournisseur de la restauration
indépendante depuis 50 ans l'entreprise
s'est proposé pour être le lien entre
les villes et les restaurateurs et en
leur apportant aussi la red
ils se fournissent à la fois en
alimentaire mais le nouveau besoin de la
vente à emporter et de plus en plus
présent donc on les fournit aussi là
dessus
voilà et c'est vrai que c'est pas leur
métier de base d'être sur les marchés
donc on leur offre aussi un soutien
logistique
ce matin là sur le marché beaucoup de
curieux et de clients satisfaits nous
tous a très très bien nous fait souvent
portée parce que on considère que ça
leur permet de tenir le coup
on espère qu'ils vont surmonter la crise
et qu'ils pourront trouver après donc je
pense est pour bat tous ses frères un
petit effort pour le soutenir
cette opération devrait perdurer dans
les semaines à venir jusqu'à peut-être
une prochaine réouverture des
restaurants